foreign
[Music]
come on 21 minutes ago in comes order
Hamilton button and Smith eight extra
large deep dish pizzas in eight minutes
I am defaulting on Joe's 29 minute
guarantee then not only am I deceiving
no money for these pizzas but I will
lose the customer forever two pizza here
look you are my only hope all right you
have to make it in time Peter you're a
nice guy but you're just not dependable
is your last chance you have to go 42
blocks in seven and one half minutes but
your ass is fire
go
[Music]
[Music]
what is stupid
[Music]
thank you
he stole that guy's Pizza
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hey you guys no playing in the streets
yes Mr Spiderman
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Pizza Time
you're late
I'm not paying for those
just 29 minute guarantee is a promise
man
I know to you Parker a promise means
nothing
but to me it's serious
serious to me too Mr Aziz you fired go
please I need this job you're fired give
me another chance
[Music]